howdy defear
est le seul et unique américain du
célèbre groupe britannique
monty python
eh bien cela a donné aux autres une chance de se sentir
supérieurs parce que
je ne parlais pas la langue aussi bien
qu'eux parce qu'ils se sentaient supérieurs
ils se sont détendus et j'ai pu  faire toutes
les choses que je voulais vraiment faire
les autres devaient travailler plus sur un pied d'égalité
mais j'avais plus de liberté c'était
très agréable j'ai aussi appris à parler
anglais en même temps
quand comment et pourquoi as-tu travaillé en france
renee garcini
ah c'était  il y a longtemps, c'était en
1965, je pense,
et je m'étais arrêté en
Europe et j'avais manqué d'argent et j'avais
besoin de retourner en Amérique
et je connaissais rene gassini d'un dîner à
new york et je l'ai appelé
il était  l'éditeur de pilate j'ai dit que j'avais
besoin d'argent et il a dit d'accord
voici deux pages en p-lot remplissez-les
de dessins il m'a donné de l'argent j'ai
[musique]
maison
tortue tu sais où le reste du
gang n'est
pas  un indice
[Musique
] c'est précisément le genre de chose  que
personne ne croit jamais
bien
tu y vas en premier alors sally
attention
wow
vas-y  ceci à partir de je l'ai coupé
du haut
du haut en fait où d'autre
pensez-vous que je l'obtiens de
oui oui oui épissure jusqu'à la fin afin que nous
puissions continuer notre descente
oh très intelligent génial
pourquoi n'ai-je pas pensé à ça c'est pourquoi
il est  un baron
et je suis une preuve
[Musique]
et les tchèques essaient un autre film sur les coups de lune
mr smart guy ah parce que le mien est meilleur
je pense qu'aucun d'eux n'a
vraiment capturé la folie du
munchausen original
pourquoi avez-vous choisi john neville et  pas
sean
connery marlon brando ou paul newman ou même
peter ou deux
pourquoi je préfère juste avoir un personnage
qui n'existe que
dans ce film particulier
comme un jeu c'est important
[Musique]
vous avez dépensé 40 millions de dollars sur cette
version de moonshot se
ferme euh à votre  idée originale 100
peut-être mo  re peut-être moins hein mais
c'est probablement environ quatre-vingts pour cent
du film que nous avons commencé
mais cela s'est produit sur tous les films que j'ai
faits au Brésil j'ai dû perdre de
grandes quantités aussi sur les bandits du temps
euh l'important est le film quand
il est fini il encore  est le film que je
voulais,
l'essence est là et je pense que
si j'avais été capable de faire exactement ce que j'avais
prévu, nous serions toujours en train de tourner le film en
ce moment
et euh l'italie serait probablement le
pays le plus riche du monde et tout  les
studios seraient en faillite et
nous aurions besoin de 10 heures pour regarder
le film, donc
j'ai un peu compromis
[Musique]
wow
euh c'était une chose inquiétante
parce que
j'avais beaucoup confiance en putnam et
je le connaissais  et je lui ai fait confiance
en fait, les nouvelles personnes allaient bien,
ce qui était intéressant, c'est qu'elles étaient tellement
occupées
euh à se battre pour une position et à se
poignarder dans le dos quand les nouvelles
personnes sont arrivées qu'elles n'ont pas remarqué que
nous faisions un film
alors nous  était totalement libre de faire le film
la façon dont nous voulions alors
oui tout allait bien comment réagissez
-vous quand vous vous appelez
l'anglo-saxon federico fellini
c'est un merveilleux compliment je peux mourir
heureux maintenant
maintenant terry pouvez-vous nous expliquer les
problèmes que vous avez
eu avec le brésil aux États-Unis  déclare
ouais le film était sorti en
europe
et avait du succès mais c'était un
distributeur différent en amérique
et ils estimaient que les américains étaient moins
sophistiqués
que les européens et que nous devions
avoir une fin heureuse sur ce film et
j'ai dit que ce n'était pas possible  ce n'est pas
l'histoire que nous avons convenu de raconter au
début
et si vous voulez faire une histoire différente
alors nous ferons un autre film et donc j'ai
eu ce très long combat qui a pris neuf
ou dix mois
pour sortir le film nous avons fini par avoir
d'avoir des
projections secrètes pour les
critiques de Los Angeles et euh
à la fin de l'année, ils ont voté pour
les meilleurs films et ils ont découvert
dans les lois de leur organisation que
le film n'avait pas vraiment à
sortir
et  ils ont réussi à voter pour la meilleure image, le
meilleur réalisateur et le
meilleur scénario et à ce moment-là, l'
universel ne pouvait plus enterrer le film
et
comment c'est arrivé, a-t-il dit si vous ne tirez pas,
vous n'êtes pas heureux
si vous tournez, vous n'êtes pas heureux non plus
qu'est-ce qu'il y a avec toi gamin
qu'est-ce que c'est hein c'est un problème
je pense que la meilleure chose est que je meure
alors je serai heureux
mais c'est que j'attendrai quelques années pour
cela est-il vrai que pour votre prochain film
vous '  je me suis rendu
au pouvoir d'hollywood oui j'ai dit
que je me suis vendu totalement j'ai vendu mon âme à
hollywood
euh je pensais avoir toujours dit que je
ne ferais jamais un film que je n'ai pas
écrit et que je ne travaillerais pas pour un
producteur hollywoodien et je ne travaillerais pas
directement pour un studio, donc
parce que je l'ai dit depuis si longtemps, j'ai
pensé qu'il était temps de le faire
et j'ai accepté de faire un film appelé
watchmen qui est basé sur une
grande bande dessinée culte je  pense qu'il a été
publié en france maintenant il s'appelle
le guardian et c'est très intéressant
ça change le rythme de ma vie  peut-être que
je serai heureux maintenant terry
est la dernière question pourriez-vous s'il vous plaît
nous raconter l'histoire
du clown poliacci il y a un homme
qui vient voir un psychiatre et
dit que je suis misérable ma femme m'a quitté
mes enfants sont morts
j'ai tout perdu  mon argent je veux
me suicider
je ne peux pas continuer et le psychiatre
lui dit bien
j'ai la réponse à tes problèmes va
ce soir voir le grand clown paliacci il
va changer ta vie et il dit
je suis politique
[Musique]
l'inaudible  bleu